I,
I have,
uh,
all daughters and I have friends that are women and I,
I have a lot of friends that are women in the world of standup comedy.
And
I oftentimes see massage,
Enos Shit online that shocks me.
And one of the things that shocked me was there's a guy that I follow and he was
talking about how his wife was,
he looked thread on Twitter.
Well thought out,
very smart guys,
a lawyer.
And I was talking about how his wife's gas tank,
so he's empty.
It's like every time he gets in his wife's car,
she's always had a gas.
He's like,
what the fuck?
Why do I always have to get gas for you?
And then she explained she doesn't like to park to get gas because she gets
harassed and it creeps her out.
And um,
and it's like a man would never think about that.
Not only men,
never think about that.
The messages he was getting from men calling him a cock making excuse.
Oh yeah.
There is,
I mean,
I am an idiot that I didn't think darkly enough because of course it was going
to go there and he told me direct messages,
getting directions,
just people you know,
saying all kinds of crazy shit to him because they,
not only are they in denial that this could be a situation where their mother
was in or their wife or their daughter.
Maybe they don't have a daughter.
Maybe they have a bad relationship with her mother.
Maybe they just,
they've had so many bet.
You know,
if a guy's had so many bad interactions with women and he's not very smart and
he's just decided that women are evil and you see anything that's like saying,
hey guys,
maybe we should look at it in terms of like how the woman looks at it.
Fuck you.
Like that's real.
Those guys are real and they're out there.
I was at a gas station the other night at two o'clock in the morning.
I was coming home from the comedy store and I pulled into this gas station and
there was this guy,
you know that you have that bulletproof thing where this thick glass and the
guy's talking to,
I'm,
I'm using my credit card and this guy is trying to use his debit card.
And uh,
I pull in,
I get out of my car and I hear yelling and I hear him going,
hey bro,
relax.
You're not a fucking bank teller or right.
He goes,
you're taking this job so seriously.
You make $10 an hour and the guy says something,
there's no money on the cars.
Like fuck you,
there's $800 on this card.
And his friend from the car saying something,
he said,
and I am nervous.
Okay,
I'm here.
Yes,
it's two o'clock in the morning and I'm nervous.
And I'm like,
fuck.
what if this guy turns any of this aggression on me?
What if he decides,
I mean,
he's a fucking asshole and he's probably drunk or high or something and it's two
o'clock in the morning and it's him and there's another guy in the car.
And I'm so nervous humiliating the guy who works.
Yes,
yes.
And I'm so nervous that I'm thinking of cutting my pumps short.
I'm thinking,
I just don't get a full tank.
Just get five bucks and get the fuck Outta here.
You know,
don't run out of gas,
but let's just get the fuck out here.
We'll get the gas tomorrow during the daylight.
And I'm a man and I'm looking at these two guys and I'm saying,
okay,
if some shit goes down,
if these guys don't have a weapon,
um,
I'm gonna beat the fuck out of these two guys.
Did they look skinny?
They look like they don't exercise,
but they're aggressive.
They're angry.
They're stupid.
My God.
Dammit.
Like all my spidey senses.
Go on,
get Outta here.
Go Get outta here.
And like an asshole.
I decided to stay and pump my gas,
but when the,
the,
these guys are yelling at each other,
I literally went around the front of the car instead of the,
this the back way because it was a shorter path from me being exposed to their
view.
So I'm hiding behind my truck while I'm filling my tank and I'm a man who could
kill these two guys.
I honestly thought where this story was going to go is that you were going to go
over and tell them to show.
I was thinking of going over there,
but I didn't want to get shot and I'm thinking,
what if this is how people die?
Now I'm saying no,
but also you can get hit in the head with a pipe,
but isn't that insane thing that you have to worry that you're going to get shot
at again?
It is.
It is,
but it's not just shot.
It's just violence in general.
And I'm,
and I'm a martial arts expert,
so I'm less worried than most men and certainly way less worried than a woman.
If I was a woman and I pulled up and I heard that guy go,
fuck you make $10 an hour,
bro,
fucking relaxed.
I'd be like,
Oh,
get me the fuck out of here.
I was on fumes though.
Raising two daughters made you so much more aware of this stuff.
100% yeah,
and also just raising babies.
Even if there were boys,
I realized that people were babies.
Now,
I used to think of people as being in a static state.
If I,
how old are you?
34 I meet you.
I go,
oh,
34 year old person.
This is a 34 year old person.
I didn't meet you in think in the past I would have met you and only thought of
you as a 34 year old person.
Now I look at everyone by default as a baby.
That's how I process things and it made me way more compassionate,
way more understanding and way more patient with people because I now I say,
okay,
when I meet this asshole at the gas station,
two o'clock in the morning that's berating that guy.
Well,
why is he?
because probably his dad's a fucking piece of shit.
His life probably sucks.
He's probably dumb.
He's probably been on drugs since he was young.
He doesn't have any smart friends.
They don't have any money to get gas at two o'clock in the morning and making
poor life choices.
There's a lot wrong here.
He doesn't have any discipline in his life.
He's never gone through any sort of trials and tribulations that taught him
about things he isn't.
Disney didn't receive life lessons,
probably didn't get a good education.
Here we are,
and I might have to kick this guy's ass cause it's two o'clock in the morning
and he's threatening.
He's loud and he's probably going to be loud to other people.
Look at them the wrong way.
He's just fucking toxic.
Really stupid.
But it was a baby.
He was a baby at one point in time.
So I don't want to go over there.
I don't want to,
I want,
I don't want to create violence.
I'm thinking it's just going to drive away.
And eventually he did.
And that poor guy who probably is probably making just a little bit more than
$10 an hour,
is stuck in this fucking cubicle,
this little glass box with this asshole berating him at two o'clock in the
morning.
But that's a baby.
That guy was a baby.